hey guys that guy oh the glasses here
and I do quite a few interviews and
every once in a while one comes along
that ask can you do a sketch for it and
I don't usually but there was a time
where I had more time to do it and this
is at you one of the sketches a rather
an audio review this is for a podcast
someone just really wanted me to do a
review of Halloween 3 and I never saw it
before and I watched it and it went on
the interview and that was that well
they forgot I had it and decided what
the heck I'll share it with you guys so
this is an audio very fast you know only
a few minutes but this is a fast audio
review I did of Halloween 3 there's also
a bum review I did on the last
presidential election that should be up
soon and yeah here it is and enjoy hello
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to remember the movie
Halloween that scary horror classic
about a killer named Michael Myers who
stalks Jamie Lee Curtis while building
suspense creepiness and terrifying
tension yeah I didn't like it either I
mean who wants to be scared while
watching a scary movie who wants all
that edge-of-your-seat action while
holding your breath hoping the main
character will make it out ok and the
sequel Halloween 2 wasn't much better it
surrounded us at a world of fun
double corners holding our attention
throughout the entire film who wants
that get the Halloween movies give us
something a little more I don't know
shittier something that's not scary not
for a finger the least bit plausible
something that backstabs the entire
franchise is if the film's before it
didn't even exist well your luck because
there's Halloween 3 and unlike those
other pesky Halloween movies Halloween 3
has absolutely nothing to do with Mike
Myers or any of the other characters
from the films this one has to deal with
something realistic like witches witches
who create Halloween masks that turn
children's heads into snakes and puns I
am not kidding
they don't do this witchcraft through
magic of course but their electronic
microchips that zaps the children's
heads into Halloween Bush what that's
not crappy enough for you
well there's also robots robots that the
witches create who bleed Campbell's
green pea soup and help them in their
plot for world domination the only
problem is they're not really looking to
take over the world they're just looking
for some good old-fashioned sacrifices
for their evil Lord who is the evil Lord
you might ask why does he need
sacrifices how the hell does this goofy
which religion work anyway well this
movie's far too busy following its hero
dr. dan chalice to answer those
questions
ah yes dr. dam Chell is one of the
underrated heroes of American cinema who
pulls off such heroic acts as bravely
cheating on his wife boldly ignoring his
children and with all pride and dignity
getting totally drunk 2:00 p.m. in the
middle of the day
take that John Carpenter trying to give
us good role models like Jamie Lee
Curtis
with that said you might be wondering
does this movie have any connection to
the original John Carpenter film well
there is one scene while dr. ban in a
bar of course is watching a trailer on
TV for the original Halloween movie with
Michael Myers and everything
so obviously this film has gone out of
his way to have absolutely nothing to do
with the original movies so why call it
Halloween 3 if it literally has nothing
to do with Halloween it's because they
both take place on Halloween night well
I guess I can understand that I'll have
to confuse a Christmas Story with Debbie
Does Dallas because both of them in the
film say the word thought I know that
seems like a lame connection but I'd
rather believe that than believe that
Hollywood was actually stupid enough to
make a Halloween sequel and forgot to
actually make it a Halloween see Walt
this is by far the strangest movie
sequel I've ever seen in my entire life
a film that is not only bad and not
scary but literally has nothing to do
with the original movie it's almost like
an April Fool's joke except it's on
Halloween and we paid money for it oh
well it could be worse I here in 2010
they're making a sequel to the mortal
with any luck maybe he'll take the
Halloween franchise probably not be
anything like its predecessors either
but in that case I think it'd be a good
thing I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to